[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire faut que sur ces entreprises
de saint quentin en yvelines qui propose
une large gamme de services pour leurs
collaborateurs salle de sport
conciergerie ou encore salle de sieste
illustration à guyancourt sur le campus
crédit agricole et l'entreprise
antemeta retour sur la 4e édition des
smart days organisés par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie yvelines
versailles près de 350 entreprises ont
pu découvrir les opportunités que
pouvait offrir l'impression 3d la
réalité augmentée atelier sur les
nouvelles ordonnances travail au ski
tube isf dans les yvelines ou encore une
entreprise rambo liten que vient qui
vient de rénover le phare de la tour
eiffel
nous ferons un point complet sur le
reste de l'actualité économique dans
notre département
mais avant de développer tous ses titres
commençons ce magazine avec un chiffres
+11 % un chiffre lié au tourisme puisque
l'insee a révélé dernièrement les
chiffres du troisième trimestre 2010 7
et bonne nouvelle la fréquentation est
en hausse en ile de france
les nuitées hôtelières ont augmenté de
11% dans la région par rapport à la même
période l'an passé
la clientèle étrangère contribue
largement à cette augmentation
toutefois on ne retrouve pas encore le
niveau de 2015 avant les attentats
comme le précise l'insee allez direction
à présent un guyancourt où s'est tenue
la quatrième édition des smart days
organisés par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie versailles yvelines la
manifestation avait plusieurs objectifs
mettre en relation les entreprises du
département mais aussi leur faire
découvrir deux technologies de
l'industrie du futur la réalité
augmentée est l'impression 3d
reportage
des rendez vous d'affaires individuels
qui côtoient des technologies très
futuriste lors de cette manifestation
annuelle consacrée à l'innovation en
plus de nouer de nombreux contacts avec
des partenaires les entreprises
yvelinoise ont notamment pu découvrir
les opportunités qu'offre l'impression
3d l'impression 3d permet la production
de masse de pièces sur mesure et on n'a
pas tous le même fémur on n'a pas tous
le même crade et donc l'impression 3d à
une débouché naturel sur l'environnement
médical mais pas que parce que toutes
les industries aujourd'hui nous
sollicitent à travers l'europe est
également aux états unis en asie
autre technologie qui a envahi notre
quotidien depuis ces dernières années la
réalité augmentée un procédé développé
notamment à elancourt dans les locaux
d'airbus defence and space on va venir
ajouter des informations digitales à
votre réalité qu'on va venir pointer des
objets et leur indiquer leur nature on a
présenté un petit peu ce qu'on a fait
autour d'une application qui est
un des premiers cas d'utilisation dans
le monde de l'éducation comment utiliser
la réalité augmentée pour améliorer nos
capacités dans le cadre du training ou
la formation guider les entreprises
yvelinoise pour qu'elles s'approprient
ces nouvelles technologies numériques
c'était la volonté de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans les
yvelines 14,1 pour cent des emplois sur
les à l'industrie contre 12,3 au niveau
au niveau national et seulement 7,6 au
niveau de toutes les régions île de
france et donc c'était aussi une bonne
raison de mettre l'accent sur
l'industrie et la piste du futur des
entreprises qui ont pu également
découvrir un nouveau dispositif open
connect lab destiné à mieux développer
leurs innovations faire de la muscu sur
son le travail entre midi et deux ou
encore se détendre en faisant une partie
de billard entre deux rendez vous ces
équipements destinés à motiver et à
fidéliser les salariés se mettent de
plus en plus en place dans les
entreprises aient compris à saint
quentin en yvelines
des entreprises comme le crédit agricole
ou encore antemeta sont aux petits soins
pour leurs collaborateurs
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage
[Musique]
un terrain de 15 hectares où des
bâtiments modernes côtoient un parc
paysager
bienvenue au skypark c'est là que sont
implantés les bureaux du crédit agricole
paiement de services is une filiale du
groupe bancaire qui s'occupe des
services de paiement le crédit agricole
s'est implanté sur ce campus dans les
années 70 c'est l'époque où notre banque
connaissait une expansion extrêmement
forte et extrêmement rapide et avait
donc besoin de s'agrandir le soin était
naturellement d'avoir des locaux qu'ils
soient compétitifs
qu'ils soient facilement accessibles et
puis la volonté était également de
donner une priorité toute particulière à
la qualité du cadre de vie
pour cela la direction propose un
certain nombre de prestations à ses
collaborateurs plusieurs points de
restauration des salles de sport pour
entretenir sa forme ou encore des salles
de repos pour méditer sur des classiques
de la littérature française
plus original la société a une rue
entière dédiée aux services
moi j'utilise surtout le pressing parce
qu'en fait je trouve ça très pratique
d'arriver le matin ont des pros sont
costumés 48 heures plus tard on le
récupère donc ya pas de contrainte à
aller sur un autre site en fait un qui
est souvent liée à du stress c'est à
dire où est ce que je vais pas être en
retard le matin parce que y ait des
bouchons le déposer les déposer dans un
dans un endroit particulier de tout ce
qui ici nous fait permet de faire gagner
du temps au quotidien en fait
et derrière ça nous permet notamment je
sais qu'avant souvent le midi j'allais
faire les deux trois courses que j'avais
besoin aujourd'hui avec la conserverie
tous les services qui sont ici le midi
ce que je fais c'est que je prend un but
casquette et je vais courir en 1978 ils
étaient 150 à travailler sur ce campus
près de quarante ans plus tard ils sont
5000 à travailler ici deuxième employeur
du territoire l'entreprise souhaite
conserver son attractivité en proposant
tous ses services
c'est d'abord effectivement un objectif
de qualité de vie au travail
ça rejoint les valeurs mutualistes et
humaines du groupe crédit agricole qui
notamment
est-ce que plus on est dans un
environnement agréable et respectueux
bien effectivement mieux on travaille
avec 5000 personnes qui travaillent sur
le campus notamment dans le domaine
technologique surtout dans le domaine
technologique
on a besoin de recruter chaque année à
peu près 1000 personnes c'est absolument
considérable et 1000 personnes de très
haut niveau donc naturellement on
souhaite que venir travailler à skypark
souhaite un must et que naturellement ce
soit avec plaisir que des candidats se
présentent pour les recrutements que
nous réalisons
un esprit silicon valley que l'on
retrouve également chez de nombreuses
pme à saint-quentin-en-yvelines images
relaxante au sol comme au mur mobilier
pour se reposer l'entreprise antemeta
située à guyancourt et spécialisée dans
le stockage de données
elle a souhaité installer cette salle de
sieste pour le bien-être de ses 150
salariés mais pas que c'est vrai qu'on
est dans l'informatique dans toutes les
start up on connaît forcément le le
billard le baby foot on a aussi un
flipper sur lequel on peut faire
quelques compétitions entre midi et deux
le soir avant de rentrer les salariés
peuvent également profiter d'une salle
de sport pendant leur pause méridienne
des services très apprécié qui
permettent de renforcer l'esprit
d'équipé est d'être attractif pour les
futurs salariés c'est fait exprès en
fait pour mettre un petit peu l'ambiance
start-up un peu à la google un esprit un
peu américain
ça permet au salarié de pouvoir se
détendre au moment des pauses et de
créer quand même quelques collisions et
kick un abonnement dans une salle de
sport ça peut être assez onéreux les
temps de déplacement en région ile de
france sont assez importants c'est
pouvoir toi tout de suite trouvé sur le
lieu de travail ce type de service et
c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi la volonté
d'être une entreprise intéressante pour
les personnes qui voudraient nous
rejoindre
labellisé haute qualité environnementale
le bâtiment accueillera également dans
quelques mois plusieurs ruches sur son
toit un moyen pour antemeta de cultiver
son image de société respectueuse de
l'environnement
les suites de notre focus sur les
services à destination des salariés de
saint quentin en yvelines des services
qui sont désormais accessibles en
quelques clics sur la toile et des
infrastructures qui ne cesse de se
développer comme cette nouvelle crèche
interentreprises qui ouvrira ses portes
dans quelques mois avec ses seize mille
entreprises et ses 142 mille personnes
qui viennent travailler quotidiennement
à saint quentin en yvelines
les services à destination des salariés
ne manquent pas sur le territoire
par exemple de nombreux espaces verts
sont disponibles pour faire un footing
pendant la pause méridienne ou encore
des centres commerciaux pour faire du
shopping pour rendre cela plus lisible
pour les entreprises et leurs salariés
l'agglomération a mis en ligne une carte
interactive la sky business map
elle permet de partir à la découverte de
l'écosystème local
c'est toutes les ressources de saint
quentin en yvelines qui sont mises à
disposition des entreprises
c'est pour elles la possibilité de
trouver un fournisseur un partenaire un
client dans l'environnement local
des pictogrammes de couleur disséminés
sur l'ensemble du territoire permettent
de visualiser les restaurants
d'entreprise lieu de séminaires ou
encore des crèches interentreprises
concernant ce dernier service il est
très apprécié des salariés c'est
l'employeur qui réservent les berceaux
en échange ils bénéficient d'être
fiscale et de crédit d'impôt sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il en existe 19
enfin bientôt vingt avec la bei et le
papillon 300 m² situé face au vélodrome
on va retrouver ici donc deux sections
deux lieux de vie pour les enfants et on
aurait également donc un espace de
psychomotricité à cet endroit là c'est
une crèche donc qui offrira 30 berceaux
sur le territoire dont 25 places qui
sont qui seront offertes est ouverte aux
salariés des entreprises
saint-quentinoise et alentour et cinq
places qui sont donc réservées à des
personnes qui sont inscrites dans des
parcours d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle cette nouvelle
crèche inter entreprises qui mettent en
avant l'égalité des chances dès le
berceau devrait être opérationnelle en
mars 2018 pour que ce projet aboutisse
la bei et le papillon a bénéficié du
soutien du ski tube à travers le
dispositif initiative sky fabien
vraiment d'un constat du territoire où
il y avait des besoins parce que sur
saint quentin en yvelines il ya quand
même un gros volume d'entreprises toutes
les demandes ne sont pas satisfaites
donc
du coup on arrive sur ce territoire
comme un plus et parmi les nouveaux
services proposés aux salariés de saint
quentin en yvelines la vélostation très
attendue elle ouvrira ses portes en
décembre et permettra notamment aux
usagers de la gare de louer des vélos ou
encore de les stationner en toute
sécurité
on passe le reste de l'actualité
économique avec un décryptage sur les
ordonnances travail une entre une
entreprise rambo liten qui vient de
rénover le fort de la tour eiffel mais
aussi cette question qui paie lisf dans
les yvelines
réponse dans l'action en bref jeudi 9
novembre le ski cube recevez une dizaine
de chefs d'entreprises autour d'un petit
déjeuner objectif en savoir plus sur les
cinq nouvelles ordonnances qui réforme
le code du travail dans l'ensemble
en dehors de ce petit bémol sur cette
barémisation qui peut être choquante
pour les salariés en une fois de plus
entre 0 et 6 ans d'ancienneté
en dehors de ça je pense que c'est
vraiment une loi qui va être libératrice
entre guillemets de de travail mais pour
tout le monde
qui paie l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune dans les yvelines
l'administration fiscale vient de
publier ses statistiques et ils sont
7129 à payer lisf dans notre département
seules les communes de plus de 20 mille
habitants ont été pris en compte
versailles arrive largement en tête avec
un impôt moyen qui dépasse les 11 mille
euros saint germain en laye et le
chesnais complète le podium
mantes la jolie et l'encours et
guyancourt ferme le classement sans lui
la tour eiffel ne serait plus la tour
eiffel après six semaines d'interruption
le phare projette de nouveaux sons
puissants faisceaux lumineux sur 80
kilomètres et ça c'est grâce à
l'entreprise en vo liten à devait
l'appel d'offres était mondiale mais
c'est le savoir-faire des douze salariés
spécialisée dans la mécatronique qui a
été choisi un contrat qui a permis à la
société d'empocher plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros mais aussi d'être
mis en lumière sur la scène
internationale
c'est au numéro touche bientôt à sa fin
mais avant voyons ensemble les rendez
vous économiques et vous attendent
vendredi 17 novembre la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines organise une matinée dédiée à
la reprise d'entreprise ce et de 9h30 à
11h30 c'est gratuit plus d'informations
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran
et puis le statut juridique de votre
entreprise un choix stratégique
et bien c'est le thème d'un atelier
mardi 21 novembre au ski tube c'est de
9h30 à 11h30
inscriptions sur le site www.skype.com
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 28
novembre pour un nouveau numéro consacré
cette fois ci à l'entrepreneuriat
féminin
à très bientôt
[Musique]